- I can get this one
right, this is my brain
trying to take a fifth grade quiz.
- I don't feel great about this.
- I was actually born in Columbia.
- I'm an adult, gotta pretty good handle
on where stuff is in the world.
- [Man] Which Great Lake
is the arrow pointing to?
- Oh fuck. I don't know.
- There are three (laughs), right?
- That is Lake Michigan.
- I'm just gonna say Lake Michigan
'cause it's right near Michigan.
- That's Lake Michigan.
- There's not like one Great Lake?
- I wouldn't have gotten that,
I'm not even gonna pretend
that I would've gotten that.
Which city is not a state capital?
- I'm going with Miami, Florida.
- I think Miami is a state capital.
- Miami, Florida is not a state capital.
- Also like Miami can't be the capital,
I'm gonna say Miami.
- I figure it's too cool and neat
to be an actual state capital.
- [Woman] Which state is Wyoming?
- The West is better because
states should be square
and 300 miles a side.
- I should know this
'cause I like go to Wyoming
every couple years.
I don't think it's B or C.
- I like the way that one's not angled,
I think this one was
trying to throw me off.
- The offset square, C.
- That one, C.
- Gonna say A, no last one
was A, see this is what I do.
This one, D.
- [Staff Member] C!
- Son of a (grunts), I knew it.
- [Man] Which state has more
coastline, Louisiana or Maine?
- Maine is so small, no
Maine isn't that small,
there's just not that many people in it.
- I feel like Louisiana
would probably have
more of a coastline.
- I was just in Louisiana,
gonna say Maine.
- I'm gonna say Maine.
- I'm gonna go with Maine because
Maine has probably more islands.
- (laughs) Yes!
- Guess that makes sense.
- Jeez Louise.
- What is the third smallest state?
Is the most ridiculous
question I have ever heard.
- Now is this by area or population?
- Probably not Connecticut.
- I know Rhode Island is pretty small.
- Connecticut also seems
small, but maybe that's
one of those secretly
big states like New York.
- I mean I know California
and Texas are really big.
- New Hampshire.
- Vermont.
- Is it New Jersey?
- Connecticut?
It's Connecticut!
(laughs)
- I think Connecticut was big.
- Yes, yes, yes!
- Yeah that was an
enlightening experience.
- Well, I got an F.
- Spend the rest of the
day looking at a map.
- It's too much pressure
to put on a fifth grader
and a 29 year old.
- Come tell me which rectangle is Wyoming.
Do you know fifth grader?
I don't think so.
Have you been anywhere?
(upbeat jazz music)